[Music]
Christmas Eve has turned into a
nightmare for a group of people being
held hostage in the Liquor Mart behind
me here's what we know for certain sent
a Santos is the owner sent a slicker
Marc Christmas very yes spare me Kate
Daniels is working the counter today
you're moving to old men in my child
hostage right now Karl's patrol vehicles
down the road and it appears to have
been in some kind of altercation may or
may not be the hostage-taker start an
act like a damn police officer thank you
sir
what are you doing here anyway
my father used to live here so I came
here to try to find them he was pardoned
arrested me for no reason
four nail Drano
the weed was his oh [ __ ] it's bunch of
dumb shits out there
the suspect was released for Christmas
get out of here we want to get everyone
out of here safely and reunited with
their loved ones oh you do we're gonna
get it Time Machine going
[Music]
no no and no no [ __ ] off you buy
yourself in a real mess here we can't
negotiate with a crazy person it's not a
damn movie Billy you're not Samuel
[ __ ] jack see
[Music]
you